idée me et les décisions qu elle rend
nécessaires pour en maîtriser la
diffusion il ya quinze jours ici même je
vous ai fait part de mon inquiétude nous
observions alors un début de reprise de
la circulation virale avec quelques
situations préoccupantes dans certains
départements
deux semaines plus tard le constat que
nous pouvons faire de la situation
confirme nos craintes
la progression de l'épidémie s'accélère
nettement
nous avons enregistré trente mille cas
pour la seule journée d'hier
35000 aujourd'hui le nombre de cas a
augmenté de 23,6 pour cent en une
semaine
cette reprise dessine en réalité ce qui
s'apparente de plus en plus clairement à
une troisième vague alors même que nous
approchons du chiffre terrible des cent
mille morts cette troisième vague
s'observe d'ailleurs à des degrés divers
dans tes ce qui s'apparente de plus en
plus clairement à une troisième vague
alors même que nous approchons du
chiffre terrible des cent mille morts
cette troisième vague s'observe
d'ailleurs à des degrés divers dans
plusieurs autres pays européens
cette troisième vague nous en
connaissons la cause l'arrivée du
variant dit britanniques qui
représentent maintenant près des trois
quarts des contaminations
ce variant britannique nous savions et
je vous l'avais dit qu'il n'était plus
contagieux
nous découvrons peu à peu qu'il est en
réalité à la fois plus virulent et
potentiellement plus grave et cela se
vérifie dans les chiffres de nos
services de réanimation hier 4269
malades de l'aco vides étaient
hospitalisés en réanimation
chaque jour environ 330 nouveaux malades
arrivent en réanimation
cela reprend une personne toutes les
quatre minutes
toutes les quatre minutes plus
inquiétant encore et olivier ferrand il
reviendra c'est arrivé en service de
réanimation concernent des personnes
plus jeunes et en meilleure santé que
lors des vagues précédentes et leur
durée de séjour à l'hôpital et
de plus en plus longues clairement ces
éléments sont plus préoccupant encore
que ce que nous pouvions comprendre de
l'évolution du virus il ya quelques
semaines encore la situation se dégrade
notre responsabilité est maintenant
qu'elle ne nous échappe pas au cours des
semaines écoulées nous étions parvenus à
contenir le niveau de progression
épidémique
grâce aux mesures adaptées que nous
avons prises mesures qui n'étaient pas
je vous le rappel des mesures légères et
faciles et vous le vivez dans votre vie
quotidienne
à savoir depuis le 16 janvier le
couvre-feu à partir de 18h dans tout le
pays
conjugué à la fermeture d'un certain
nombre d'établissements recevant du
public
nous avons également accélérer la
vaccination avec notamment des
opérations très importante le week-end
dont je voudrais féliciter l'ensemble
des acteurs nous avons également décidé
de renforcer notre stratégie tester
alerté protéger et pris des mesures
supplémentaires de restriction dans les
territoires les plus durement touchés en
mettant en place une stratégie
territorialisée fondée sur la
constatation que l'épidémie si elle
progresse partout demeure encore
disparate selon les régions
c'est ainsi que 23 départements ont été
placés sous une surveillance renforcée
et qu'un confinement le week-end a été
mis en place dans les agglomérations de
dunkerque et de nice c'était le 25
février 10 dans le département du pas de
calais le 6 mars dernier
ces décisions ont été prises sur la base
de critères sanitaires un taux
d'incidence de contamination au dessus
de 400 cas pour 100000 habitants une
pression hospitalière dans ce territoire
atteignant déjà la cote d' alerte et une
dynamique les sentes entrevoir une nette
dégradation si rien n'était fait pour
l'enrayer
compte tenu des disparités régionales
qui ré
c'est aujourd'hui encore importante
cette stratégie territorialisée conserve
son sens et sa pertinence
mais la situation appelle des mesures
beaucoup plus forte dans un plus grand
nombre de départements au cours des tous
derniers jours deux régions on franchit
on s'apprête à franchir ces seuils l'île
de france et au de france en ile de
france
l'incidence est aujourd'hui de 446 ce
qui représente une hausse très forte de
plus de 23% en une semaine
plus préoccupant encore la pression
hospitalière et je pense à cet instant à
nos personnels soignants atteint
aujourd'hui un niveau très élevé il y à
ce soir près de 1200 personnes admises
en réanimation
annie de france c'est déjà plus que le
niveau qui avait été atteint au pic de
la deuxième vague au mois de novembre
grâce aux efforts considérables de tous
les établissements publics comme privés
de tous les professionnels
nous avons encore augmenter nos
capacités d'accueil en soins intensifs
en réanimation et nous pouvons encore
accueillir au moins 300 à 500 malades
supplémentaires dans la région des hauts
de france le taux d'incidence s'élève ce
soir à 381,1 et si le seuil de 400 n'est
pas encore atteint il devrait l'être
très rapidement au vu des rythmes de
progression que nous enregistrons il est
vrai que la situation épidémique n'est
pas équivalente entre les différents
départements mais la situation critique
des services hospitaliers de cette
région y est maintenant partout très
préoccupante comme en ile de france le
pic de la deuxième vague a également été
atteint et même dépassé
il en est de même des départements de la
seine-maritime et de l'eure où l'on
observe des niveaux d'incidence moindre
mais deux éléments critiques une
augmentation très forte et surtout des
capacités de réanimation déjà presque
totalement de saturer
dans tous ces territoires de nouvelles
mesures doivent donc intervenir sans
délai le confinement le week-end qui
s'applique dans les alpes maritimes et
le pas de calais depuis quelques
semaines a eu un effet réel mais le
bilan que l'on peut en faire et qu'il
est insuffisant pour casser fortement la
dynamique de l'épidémie qui s'accélère
dans le pas-de-calais la situation s'est
stabilisée mais peine à s'améliorer dans
les alpes maritimes une réelle baisse
observée dans un premier temps semble
s'atténuer depuis quelques jours je
voudrais saluer la mobilisation de la
population et des élus de ces
territoires qui s'arc-boutent pour
lutter contre la pandémie
mais face à l'accélération du virus et
face à la pression qui s'accentue sur
nos services hospitaliers nouveau nous
devons désormais le moment est venu
aller plus loin et mettre en oeuvre des
mesures plus exigeantes dans les
départements dont la situation est la
plus critique ces départements sont donc
au nombre de 16 il s'agit des huit
départements d'île de france et cinq
départements des hauts de france
et puis les alpes-maritimes la seine
maritime et l'eure le gouvernement a
procédé à des concertations avec leurs
élus locaux et j'ai moi même reçu hier
les présidents des assemblées et des
groupes parlementaires dans ses seize
départements de nouvelles mesures de
freinage massive de l'épidémie
interviendront à compter de ce vendredi
soir minuit et pour quatre semaines
cette une troisième voie que nous
retenons une voie qui doit permettre de
freiner sans enfermer ces mesures de
confinement ne seront pas la reprise
telle quelle de celle que nous avions
mise en place en mars et en novembre
dernier car depuis le début de
l'épidémie il y a exactement un an le
temps a passé la crise a duré mais nous
avons appris en mars 2020 pris par la
brutalité de la première vague
nous avons appliqué un confinement
nationale particulièrement strictes
incluant la fermeture des écoles une
présence au travail très réduite en
novembre nos mesures ont permis de
laisser les établissements scolaires
ouverts et nous avons rapidement basculé
à une logique de couvre-feu et
d'ouverture encadrée depuis le mois de
janvier nous nous avons opté pour une
stratégie qui nous distingue des autres
pays européens
contrairement à beaucoup de nos voisins
nous n'avons pas appliqué de confinement
au long cours à l'échelle de tout le
pays nous avons même écarté cette option
fin janvier dernier et c'était la bonne
décision car si nous avions dû confiner
alors dans une logique d'anticipation
nous aurions alors infligé au pays un
confinement de probablement trois mois
cela aurait été excessif est
insupportable et nous avons bien fait de
ne pas suivre les prévisions de certains
modèles qui indiquait un emballement de
l'épidémie dès la mi février ce qui ne
s'est pas produit grâce à notre
mobilisation collective
l'allemagne par exemple applique un
confinement strict depuis trois mois
en fermant ses crèches et ses écoles et
en décalant aujourd'hui la levée
compte tenu des nouveaux effets du
variant l'italie a connu déjà trois
confinement et vient vous l'avez vue
d'en décider
un quatrième au moment où ce pays est
atteint comme nous par cette nouvelle
vague épidémique liés aux variants dit
britannique avec le président de la
république que nous avons toujours
privilégié une approche pragmatique
proportionnée et territorialisées cette
approche nous a permis de freiner
pendant plusieurs semaines la
circulation du virus
malgré d'apparition puis la progression
du variant anglais notre conviction est
que si de nouvelles mesures s'avère
aujourd'hui nécessaire
nous devons continuer avec la même
cohérence c'est à dire privilégier une
approche pragmatique proportionnée et
terry
réalisés ne pas appliquer mécaniquement
les mêmes mesures qui errent prendre en
compte ce que cette épidémie nous a
appris dans les 16 départements
concernés par ces nouvelles mesures
nous maintiendrons le parti pris de
laisser les écoles ouvertes préserver
autant que possible
l'éducation de nos enfants il s'agit
d'un choix qui nous distingue de
beaucoup de nos voisins et que nous
entendons préserver aussi longtemps que
cela sera possible
les écoles maternelles les écoles
élémentaires et les collèges
fonctionneront donc normalement pour les
lycées qui sont déjà pour plus des deux
tiers en 2011 ils basculeront en
totalité dans ce fonctionnement et les
universités continueront à fonctionner
selon le rythme actuellement en vigueur
pour tenir compte des besoins des élèves
nous assoupliront les conditions dans
lesquelles l'activité sportive des
mineurs pour être pratique et
l'éducation physique et sportive sur le
temps scolaire pourra reprendre
normalement et les activités sportives
extrascolaires en plein air des mineurs
seront maintenus de même dans ces
territoires toujours les règles
s'appliquant aux lieux de culte
resteront inchangés s'agissant des
commerces comme en mars et en novembre
seuls les commerces vendant des biens et
des services de première nécessité
seront autorisés à ouvrir cette notion
de biens de première nécessité sera
étendue aux livres et à la musique ce
qui permettra au libraire et disquaire
de rester ouverts par souci d'équité les
restrictions de vente s'appliqueront aux
mêmes produits qu'ils savoir qu'ils
soient vendus dans un rayon de grandes
surfaces un commerce spécialisé ou un
petit commerce de centre ville
je sais que les commerçants mis en place
des protocoles sanitaires strictes mais
pour ralentir l'épidémie
il faut réduire les risques de croiser
de virus et donc les occasions de
contact dans les lieux clos dès lors la
fermeture d'une partie des commerces
doit y contribuer indépendamment des
risques spécifiques liés à leur
fréquentation
c'est d'ailleurs ce que tous les pays
autour de nous se sont résolus à faire
s'agissant des déplacements hors du
domicile notamment pour pouvoir s'aérer
se promener faire du feu sport ils
seront encadrés
mais selon des règles plus souples qu'en
mars et novembre dernier car on sait
aujourd'hui qu'on se contaminent
infiniment moins quand on se promène en
plein air qu en étant regroupés sans
masque à l'intérieur je sais également
ce qu'elle aspirations profondes de
beaucoup d'entre vous de pouvoir
profiter des espaces extérieurs alors
que la crise dure depuis maintenant une
année et que nous avançons vers le
printemps
concrètement il sera possible de sortir
de chez soi pour se promener s'aérer ou
faire du sport en journée sans aucune
limitation de durée
mais avec une attestation et à la
condition de rester dans un rayon limité
à 10 km autour de chez soi pour les
habitants des territoires concernés les
déplacements inter régionaux seront par
ailleurs interdit sauf motif impérieux
ou professionnels
le dispositif de couvre-feu sera
maintenu
selon les mêmes règles qu'aujourd'hui
avec une différence cependant l'heure de
début passera de 18 heures pardon de 18
heures à 19 heures et cet ajustement lié
à l'arrivée prochaine de l'heure d'été
s'appliquera à compter de samedi
prochain et concernera tous les
départements et pas seulement ceux
soumis à des mesures renforcées
ce choix de moins restreindre les
possibilités de sortir de chez soi doit
cependant s'accompagner d'une vraie
vigilance il s'agit clairement de rendre
possible le fait à l'extérieur
mais pas d'aller chez des amis pour y
faire la fête ou de s'y retrouver en
nombre sans distance ni masque on sait
je le répète que ce sont d'abord dans ce
type de circonstances que le virus
prospère de même rendre plus facile les
activités en extérieur ne doit pas être
le prétexte à barbecue entre amis à des
regroupements dans l'espace public ou
dans les parcs et jardins ou encore à
des attroupements devant certains bars
qui servent à boire ou à manger en vente
à emporter des consignes strictes seront
passées au préfet pour interdire la
fréquentation de certains espaces
publics ou même les manifestations et
regroupements quand leurs conditions
d'organisation créer un vrai risque
sanitaire
la règle du jeu est claire elle s'appuie
sur un principe de confiance et de
responsabilité je dirais même de bon
sens et certainement pas
d'infantilisation profitons librement
des espaces extérieurs
mais soyons hyper rigoureux pour
proscrire les regroupements privé ou
dans l'espace public
au-delà de ces mesures régissant les
déplacements personnels
nous devons également être très vigilant
sur les risques de contamination sur les
lieux de travail
la dernière étude réalisée par
l'institut pasteur montre que ces lieux
représente 29 % des cas identifiés cela
plaide pour que dans les prochaines
semaines toutes les entreprises toutes
les administrations qui le peuvent
pousse au maximum le télétravail tout en
maintenant toujours une journée sur
place pour les salariés qui le
souhaitent au moins quatre jours sur
cinq en télétravail c'est l'objectif
qu'il faut atteindre et reconnaissant le
beaucoup d'entreprises en sont encore
loin aujourd'hui
cela plaide aussi pour être plus
attentif aux conditions dans lesquelles
se font les déplacements entre le
domicile et le travail
l'étude pasteur que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure montre que la fréquentation des
transports en commun seraient moins à
risque que le covoiturage pour une
raison simple
le port du masque est bien mieux
respectée dans les métros et les trains
que dans les véhicules personnels
il ne s'agit pas d'interdire le
covoiturage ce serait totalement
excessif mais je veux rappeler à tous
ceux qui le pratiquent l'absolue
nécessité de respecter les gestes
barrière se là plaide enfin pour que les
salariés qui ont le moindre symptôme de
la maladie ne se rendent pas autrement
cela peut sembler ovide évident mais nos
données statistiques montrent que ce
n'est pas toujours le cas puisque près
de la moitié des contaminations en
milieu professionnel sont causés par des
personnes qui sont venues travailler
alors qu'elle était déjà symptomatique
de même nous savons que le moment des
repas sur les lieux de travail est
forcément une source de risque
j'ai donc demandé à la ministre du
travail et à la ministre de la fonction
publique d'établir d'ici le début de la
semaine prochaine
après concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux un protocole significativement
renforcée pour la restauration
collective en entreprise les mesures que
je vous annonce se traduiront dans les
départements concernés toute la semaine
j'en ai bien conscience par des
contraintes supplémentaires pour nos
concitoyens vivent dans ces départements
ce ne sont pas de bonnes nouvelles et je
sais la lassitude qui est la vôtre
face à cette succession de mesures qui à
l'image du virus lui même vont et
viennent évolue et s'adapte à mesure que
la crise dure ces mesures je les crois
absolument indispensable et équilibrée
elle vise à freiner le virus sans nous
enfermer le virus a accéléré depuis
maintenant 15 jours la pression sur les
services hospitaliers s'est accentuée
depuis une bonne semaine
le moment est venu d'en tirer les
conséquences
ça signifie que ces mesures que nous
prenons aujourd'hui dans les régions les
plus impactés pourront être étendue si
nécessaire à d'autres parties du
territoire cela signifie que les mesures
que nous prenons aujourd'hui ont
vocation à s'appliquer au moins
les quatre prochaines semaines car c'est
le temps nécessaire pour qu'elle
produise un effet suffisant
sauf si bien entendu des résultats
positifs significatifs étaient constatés
dans l'intervalle c'est aussi le temps
qu'il nous faut par ailleurs pour
atteindre un premier palier très
important ni avril dans la vaccination
des plus vulnérables pendant un an
non nous avons lutté contre le virus par
des mesures de restriction
l'enjeu des prochaines semaines c'est de
réduire ses mesures de restriction et de
revenir progressivement à une vie
normale à mesure que nous vaccinerons de
plus en plus de nos concitoyens car
c'est bien la campagne de vaccination
qui va nous permettre de sortir de cette
crise
cette campagne progresse et s'accélère
fortement
nous avons ce soir près de 5,7 millions
de personnes qui ont été vaccinées en
première injection
nous avons atteint un rythme de
vaccinations quotidiennes
parmi les plus élevés de l'union
européenne j'insiste aussi et encore sur
le fait qu'avec notre stratégie de
priorisation nous vaccinons les bonnes
personnes c'est-à-dire les personnes les
plus fragiles nous avons par exemple
quasiment terminé la vaccination des
résidents des ehpad qui représente 1% de
la population française mais 30% des
décès dus à la co vide près de 45 % de
l'ensemble des personnes de plus de 75
ans ont reçu une première injection
près d'une personne sur deux c'est
absolument essentiel car ce sont elles
que nous devons protéger en priorité si
nous voulons relâcher la pression sur
l'hôpital et lever les restrictions
sanitaires
je veux insister sur un point il faut
aller le plus loin possible dans la
vaccination des personnes de plus de 75
ans dans les centres de vaccination de
plus en plus de rendez-vous sont
disponibles et certains ont désormais du
mal à trouver preneur je vous engage
très fortement à vous inscrire avant que
nous nous trions la vaccination aux
personnes plus jeunes
ce que je souhaite faire assez désormais
la progression de notre campagne vous le
savez a été retardée du fait de la
décision que nous avons prise lundi avec
le président de la république de
suspendre l'utilisation du vaccin
astrazeneca dans l'attenté de l'avis de
l'agencé européenne du médicament
cette décision a été prise à titre de
précaution
en france comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays européens
et quand bien même quand bien même nous
avions recensé un nombre très limité de
cas suspects dans notre pays cette
suspension de quelques jours devait
ainsi permettre aux autorités
scientifiques européennes d'examiner les
cas suspects et de rendre un avis sur
les conditions d'utilisation de ce
vaccin
c'est une démarche prudente certes mais
indispensable en termes de confiance et
de transparence
l'agencé européenne du médicament vient
il y à quelques minutes de rendre la vie
que nous attendions
ils confirment que le vaccin astrazeneca
est un vaccin qui est non seulement très
efficace pour lutter contre l'apparition
de formes graves de la maladie mais
aussi un vaccin sûr sans danger pour
être plus précis le vaccin astrazeneca
n'est pas associée à une augmentation du
risque global de caillots sanguins chez
les sujets qui le reçoivent
de même contrairement aux suspicions qui
ont pu avoir cours
il n'y a aucune preuve d'un problème lié
à des lots spécifiques du vaccin ou à
des sites de fabrication particulier ce
que signale l'agencé européenne du
médicament
ce sont des effets secondaires
extrêmement rare liée à un faible taux
de plaquettes sanguines et apparaissant
chez des personnes majoritairement âgés
de moins de 55 ans mais je le répète la
georgie très clairement que l'efficacité
des
très du vaccin astrazeneca dans la
prévention des hospitalisations et des
décès liés aux qu'ovide l'emportent très
largement sur la probabilité extrêmement
faible de développer des effets
secondaires dès demain matin la haute
autorité de santé françaises qui est
chargé dans notre pays de formuler les
indications de tel ou tel vaccin
actualisera sa recommandation s'agissant
du vaccin
astrazeneca afin que nous puissions
reprendre immédiatement
dans la foulée dès demain après midi la
campagne de vaccination
et comme je lai déjà indiqué je me ferai
moi-même vacciner demain après midi avec
ce vaccin pour montrer que nous pouvons
avoir toute confiance
je veux en profiter précisément pour
tenir toute ma confiance et tout mon
soutien aux professionnels de santé de
ville médecin comme pharmacien qui
pourront reprendre la vaccination dès
demain après midi et que je remercie
pour leur engagement sans faille dans la
course de vitesse que nous menons grâce
à cela et aux livraisons qui arrivent
nous tiendrons les objectifs que nous
nous sommes fixés jeudi 10 3 chiffres 10
20 30 10 nous voulons avoir vacciné dès
la mi-avril au moins 10 millions de
personnes soit la quasi totalité des
personnes vulnérables volontaire
aujourd'hui éligibles à la vaccination
c'est à dire toutes les plus de 75 ans
est parmi les personnes de plus de 50
ans celles qui présentent un risque face
à la maladie vingt deux voulons avoir
vacciné d'ici mi-mai au moins 20
millions de personnes soit la totalité
de la population volontaires de plus de
50 ans et 30 nous voulons avoir vacciné
d'ici mai juin 30 millions de personnes
soit les deux tiers de la population de
plus de 18 ans volontaire concrètement
cela veut dire que ceux qui ne sont pas
encore éligibles à la vaccination vont
bien
pour pouvoir y accéder les personnes de
plus de 65 ans qui ne présente pas de
comorbidité pourront ainsi se faire
vacciner à partir de la mi-avril pour
les adultes de plus de 50 ans la
vaccination sera ouverte à partir de la
mi mai la progression des livraisons va
nous permettre de tenir ses objectifs
d'autant que nous recevrons à partir de
la mi-avril les doses d'un nouveau
vaccin
james johnson & johnson qui a été
autorisée en europe et en france et
l'organisation que nous avons mis en
place va nous permettre de répartir
toutes ces doses sur le territoire
national et de les utiliser le plus
rapidement possible nous avons sonné la
mobilisation générale pour que nous
allions encore plus vite pour multiplier
les points de vaccination pour vacciner
sans relâche tous les jours de la
semaine y compris le week-end vous
pouvez désormais vous faire vacciner
chez votre médecin ou votre pharmacien
vous pouvez aussi vous rendre dans un
centre de vaccination il y en a déjà
environ 1500 france et nous allons en
créer davantage avec les maires et les
élus locaux que je remercie une nouvelle
fois pour leur engagement
grâce à la mobilisation admirable des
hôpitaux des médecins de ville des
pharmaciens des pompiers et de tous ses
acteurs que je croise à chaque fois que
je me déplace sur le terrain
nous mettrons tout en oeuvre pour gagner
cette course contre la montre et nous
allons et nous allons y arriver je
demande maintenant à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
de vous préciser la situation épidémique
merci monsieur le premier ministre hier
avec le président de la république nous
étions à l'hôpital de poissy
nous y avons rencontré des médecins
infectiologues réanimateurs ses médecins
ont demandé d'insister à nouveau sur le
parcours de soins des malades du co lead
et sur la manière dont les choses sont
organisées
voici donc comment les choses se passent
si vous devez être contaminé par le co
lead parce qu' un certain nombre
d'éléments doivent être rappelés d'abord
je ne dirai jamais assez dès que vous
avez des symptômes et sans attendre le
résultat d'un test positif isolé vous
restez chez vous et prévenez votre
entourage
si vous êtes diagnostiqués positifs que
ce soit en test pcr en test antigénique
ou bien si vous êtes déclaré qu'à
contacter là aussi isolé vous restez
chez vous et si vous avez des symptômes
prévenez votre médecin traitant c'est
très important de prévenir votre médecin
traitant de manière à ce qu'ils puissent
suivre votre état de santé vous
surveiller et éventuellement vous
proposer des traitements si la situation
devait l'exiger
y compris d'ailleurs par télémédecine
dans le service de réanimation hier
certains malades avaient été admis en
catastrophe à l'hôpital ils étaient
restés chez eux avec leurs symptômes
n'avait pas nécessairement perçu qu'ils
étaient en hypoxie qu'il manquait
d'oxygène et qu'ils avaient besoin de
soins et ils se sont rendus compte trop
tard de leur état de santé justifiant un
transfert pour des soins lourds de
réanimation et puis si vous êtes chez
vous isolez qu'à contacter tout cas
positif je rappelle qu'on vous proposera
systématiquement le passage une
infirmière ou d'un infirmier libéral
chez vous pour tester votre entourage
vérifier que les conditions sont réunies
de qui permette votre bonne période
d'isolement voire vous proposer des
solutions alternatives et un support
administratif auprès des cellules
territoriales d'appui à l'isolément qui
sont très actives sur le territoire et
que je remercie pour cela
dans certains cas on pourra vous
proposer des médicaments un traitement
si vous avez par exemple des troubles
respiratoires
on pourra vous proposer de l'oxygène y
compris d'ailleurs chez vous ça se fait
dans un grand nombre de situations pour
vous permettre de mieux respirer
on pourra également vous prescrire des
traitements dans certaines indications
précises telles que des anticoagulants
pour éviter les risques de thrombose des
antibiotiques pour éviter le risque de
pneumonie et de la cortisone des dérivés
de cortisone si vous deviez vous
aggravez si vous êtes à risque de formes
graves avec ou sans symptômes sérieux on
pourra désormais vous proposer des
traitements innovants dont la france
s'est équipée et qui sont véritablement
porteur d'espoir parce qu'ils ont montré
dans des études notamment des études
américaines que lorsqu'ils sont
prescrits
toucher des gens à forme de risque de
formes graves essentiellement des gens
âgés de 70 ans et plus atteints de
comorbidité lorsque ces traitements
qu'on appelle les anticorps monoclonaux
en bithérapie sont prescrites aux ils
peuvent éviter des formes graves toutes
les équipes de recherche et médical sur
tout le territoire national sont
mobilisés et ce traitement pourra vous
est proposée si vous répondez à ces
critères si votre état clinique devait
néanmoins s'aggraver votre médecin
pourrait être amené à vous hospitalisés
dans des unités spécialisées dicko vide
de manière à vous soigner et à
surveiller l'évolution de votre maladie
si nécessaire vous pourrez être placé
sous oxygénothérapie y compris de
l'oxygène à haut débit nous déployons
dans tous les hôpitaux dans toutes les
cliniques des unités qu'ovide en
transformant des lits de médecine et
nous libérons des lits de médecine que
nous transformons à partir de lits de
soins de suite et de réadaptation
si votre état clinique devait vraiment
s'aggravait vous pourriez alors être
transférés dans des unités de soins
qu'on appelle des soins continus des
soins intensifs voir des unités de
réanimation et dans certains cas les cas
les plus graves
vous pourriez être placé sous assistance
respiratoire sous ventilation mécanique
et être mis en commun médicamenteux le
temps nécessaire à l'issue de ses soins
surtout si vous avez une forme grave
vous pourriez être amené à suivre des
soins de rééducation de réadaptation
pour récupérer toutes les fonctions
perdu et retrouvé de l'énergie
enfin si vous deviez garder des
séquelles au delà de quelques semaines
tels que la perte de goût et l'odorat
des céphalées une grande fatigue des
douleurs notamment des douleurs
articulaires
en somme que vous présentiez ce qu'on
appelle un qu'ovide l'ont alors vous
seriez orienter votre vers votre médecin
généraliste de nombreuses
recommandations de nombreux travaux sont
menés dans notre pays pour permettre
d'accompagner les malades et de
permettre davantage d'accélérer la
guérison notamment avec des soutien
psycho quand c'est nécessaire et de la
rééducation qui dès et des traitements
médicamenteux en fonction des symptômes
que vous pourriez présentez vous le
voyez soigner le coc vide
c'est un travail d'équipé
entre ville et hôpital médecins et
soignants dont le rôle d'ailleurs des
soignants est absolument inestimable
pour limiter les risques de
complications et prendre soin de vous en
toutes circonstances toute cette filière
de soins elle se structure
elle s'adapte selon les besoins plus le
nombre de malades est important plus
nous ouvrons de lit plus nous mobilisons
les soignants tout ceci se fait au prix
d'efforts continus de soignants qui sont
fatigués et qui sont éprouvés depuis
plus d'un an
même s'ils reçoivent le soutien le
renfort de soignants retraités
d'étudiants d'infirmiers libéraux et de
la réserve sanitaire par exemple rien
que dans la région auvergne rhône-alpes
ce sont plus de 1000 infirmiers
hospitaliers qui ont été formés aux
gestes réanimatoires pour prêter main
forte à leurs collègues notre capacité
hospitalière
elle est extensible à les mêmes très
extensible mais elle n'est pas
extensible à l'infini
surtout avec la fatigue des soignants
parfois souvent à nouveau désormais il
faut aussi libéré du personnel il faut
transformer des lits en déprogrammant
des soins pour que des malades de kovy
depuis se trouver de la place est donc
un certain nombre d'opérations
chirurgicales par exemple ne peuvent pas
être proposés aux malades qui en ont
besoin évidemment au préserve
l'essentiel la chirurgie urgente la
chirurgie cancérologique mais on sait
que les déprogrammations ont un coût en
matière de santé pour les personnes qui
doivent repousser leurs interventions
parfois de plusieurs semaines parfois
pour plusieurs mois le niveau de
déprogrammation des soins dans la région
ile de france a atteint des niveaux très
élevés enfin quand les plaçant en
réanimation se font encore plus rare il
nous faut parfois transférer des malades
du co lead en coma mais stabilisé vers
d'autres régions
ce qu'on appelle des évacuations
sanitaires elles ont accéléré ces
dernières semaines elles ont accéléré
ces derniers jours et elles continueront
à accélérer mais ce n'est pas simple
c'est même de plus en plus compliqué
d'abord
tous les malades ne sont pas
transférables il faut que leur état de
santé soient compatibles avec un
transport et parfois l'entourage refuse
le transfert du patient qui éloigne les
malades de leurs proches
enfin un transfert une évacuation
sanitaire ça mobilise beaucoup d'énergie
et beaucoup de temps de soignants
expérimenté tout le parc hospitalier
français est mobilisé
j'ai envie de vous dire nous y sommes en
ile-de-france en othe france
nous avons d'ores et déjà dépassé le
niveau maximal de patients admis en
réanimation
lors du pic de la deuxième vague en
cause des admissions en plus grand
nombre vous le voyez sur ses courbes des
durée moyenne de séjour en réanimation
qui sont plus longues des patients qui
sont parfois plus jeunes notamment du
fait des variants et des prises en
charge en réanimation qui ont pu être
retardée parce que nous avons renforcé
la prise en charge en ville mais qui du
coup peuvent se voir complexifier dans
un certain nombre de cas nous y faisons
face je le disais tout le parc
hospitalier français est mobilisé
secteur public comme secteur privé dans
les régions sous tension comme dans les
autres d'ailleurs qui sont amenés à
accueillir des patients qui seraient
transférés et nous savons que ces
efforts vont encore croître dans les
semaines à venir la montée des
réanimations est importante elle le
restera dans les prochaines semaines il
faudra encore tenir
comme nous l'avons fait lors des deux
premières vagues il faudra encore
soutenir de soignants et n'oublie pas
les milliers d'agents des agences
régionales de santé ou de l'assurance
maladie qui sont mobilisés eux aussi
depuis plus d'un an sans relâche et sans
lesquels rien de tout cela ne serait
possible
un dernier mot souvent on se contaminent
au coronavirus sans comprendre pourquoi
un virus peut déjouer nos barrières
il est microscopique invisible il se
faufile plus nous respectons les gestes
barrière plus nous limitons les risques
en définitive on n'est jamais
responsable quand on tombe malade jamais
on est toujours victime
mais même si c'est dur même si c'est
rageant même si ça nous semble durer une
éternité on doit toujours faire
attention
la moitié des contaminations vous l'avez
dit monsieur le premier ministre
en milieu professionnel sont le fait de
personnes qui bien qu'ayant des
symptômes et ne sachant pas encore
positif au co vide était quand même
aller travailler dès que vous avez des
symptômes et sans attendre les résultats
du test
restez chez vous parfois c'est le petit
craquage qui va provoquer de gros dégâts
je ne compte plus les témoignages de
médecins en réanimation les médecins de
ville qui me parle de ces soirées entre
copains de ces réunions de famille de
cette petite exception vont croire
innocente qu'on pense sans risque et qui
peut se terminer par de nombreuses
contaminations vivre avec le virus
ce n'est je n'ai pas oublié qu'il peut
toucher n'importe qui n'importe quand et
c'est vivre quand même et on le peut
grâce au port du masque grâce aux gestes
barrières grâce à la distance vis-à-vis
des autres à distance physique et grâce
à l'aération des pièces
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des
gens qui vous entourent merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre mes chers
concitoyens
j'ai parfaitement conscience des efforts
qu à nouveau je vous demande ce soir
tous les pays d'europe sont confrontés
aux mêmes souffrances et aux mêmes
difficultés que nous le variant s'y
développent de manière certes inégal
mais de manière certaine mais nous ne
pouvons pas laisser ce virus ou plutôt
désormais ses variantes poursuivre sa
route sans tout mettre en oeuvre pour
l'entraver
comme nous avons toujours tenté de le
faire jusqu'à présent
en prenant des mesures pragmatiques
proportionnée et territorialisée et en
veillant à l'équité entre les
territoires
il nous faut donc encore est à nouveau
faire face ensemble nous avons
incontestablement devant nous des jours
encore difficile nous devons toujours
davantage être derrière nous soignants
nous les applaudit sion chaque soir à
20h lors du dernier confinement il le
mérite
encore aujourd'hui nous sommes
confrontés à une troisième vague de
cette pandémie qui semble
ne pas vouloir en finir mais la grande
différence avec les vagues précédentes
c'est que nous avons devant nous
désormais une perspective cette
perspective s'appelle la vaccination et
cette perspective change tout puisque si
les efforts d'aujourd'hui sont
indispensables plus que jamais nous
savons qu'ils ne se rendent pas vain je
vous remercie même part du premier
ministre
bonjour monsieur le ministre bastia
angers pour tf1 lci vous avez évoqué un
confinement pour quatre semaines minimum
on a constaté dans le passé que
malheureusement souvent les restrictions
annoncées été renouvelé à plusieurs
reprises alors pour que les français
puissent avoir une visibilité est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire qu'elles sont très
concrètement les critères qui vous
permettront de décider de sortir de ce
confinement est l inverse quels sont les
critères qui pourraient faire que
d'autres départements subissent les
mêmes mesures et puis par ailleurs avez
vous encore un petit espoir de six
mesures fonctionnent de pouvoir
commencer à envisager des allégements à
partir de la mi avril c'est le sait le
délai qui avait été évoquée par le
président de la république
jonas
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le ministre j'ai plusieurs
questions la première c'est un troisième
confinement qui va être mis en place par
deux je me suis pas présentée et lisa
bertheaume ndtv
la première question un troisième
confinement est mis en place en inde en
est ce que vous considérez que c'est un
aveu d'échec
deuxième question vous avez plusieurs
fois mentionné monsieur le premier
ministre des perspectives de retour à la
normale est ce que vous pouvez nous déjà
nous en donner une échéance une forme
peut-être est-ce que ça sera avec ou
sans masque et puis une précision
également à vous demandez vous avez
évoqué le décalage du couvre feu de 18 à
19 heures est ce que vous pouvez pour
préciser à quelle date précisément il
sera mis en place à ce que ce sera le
samedi 20 ou le samedi 27 mars merci
beaucoup je vais céder la parole à
olivier derand d'abord pour les la
question des critères y compris pour
d'autres territoires c'est bien ça qui
basculerait pour la sortie éventuelle
des mesures de freinage actuellement
annoncées vous parlez d'un troisième
confinement je sais pas quel nom il faut
donner à ces mesures fortes qui sont
prises pour protéger les français
mais vous aurez noté qu'il ya une
différence qui est notable qui est que
nous nous tournons davantage vers
l'extérieur et que le principe
véritablement c'est de faire très
attention lorsque nous sommes regroupés
les uns les autres dans un lieu fermé
familiale personnelle amicales
professionnelles mais de pouvoir
conserver la possibilité de sortir sans
limite de durée et la saison bientôt va
pouvoir s'y prêter ça c'est un
changement qui est notable et qui fait
le constat de ce qui a pu être observé
et notamment des grandes études menées
par les épidémiologistes notamment
français qui montre qu'on se contaminent
moins à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
qu'en fait les facteurs de risque les
plus importants c'est quand on est
regroupé dans une pièce sans masque donc
c'est une c'est une différence qui est
notable même si nous avons parfaitement
conscience que pour les commerçants qui
se voient appliquer à nouveau des
mesures cela s'apparente à ce qu'ils ont
déjà pu connaître
vous dites est ce que est ce que c est
ce que c'est un constat d'échec
vous savez un virus une épidémie une
pandémie comme celle ci elle percute
tous les pays du monde et vous pouvez
regarder à l'étranger outre atlantique
ou à regarder en asie peut regarder
partout à différentes périodes de
l'année
chaque pays est percuté par des vagues
épidémiques et au fond quelles sont les
mesures qui sont mises en place quel est
le principe des mesures qui sont mises
en place pour permettre de freiner
l'épidémie est toujours le même la
distanciation sociale je le rappelle un
virus il a trois caractéristiques la
capacité à être transmis d'une personne
à une autre c'est la contagiosité
on peut pas agir sur la contagiosité en
propre d'un virus
c'est la durée pendant laquelle il est
contagieux quand on est malade ça aussi
c'est un paramètre qui est propre virus
et enfin c'est le nombre de contacts que
l'on va avoir et donc le nombre de
personnes que nous risquons de
contaminer et ce troisième paramètre
c'est celui sur lequel nous pouvons agir
donc il faut trouver je dirais avec les
connaissances que nous avons acquise le
moyen de conserver le maximum de liberté
pour les français tout en les protégeant
et de la même manière vous posez la
question des critères qui doivent nous
permettre de revenir en arrière vous
avez raison il faut donner des
perspectives aux français c'est
fondamental ce que je peux vous dire et
en tirant l'expérience de l'année
dernière c'est que lorsque les jours
deviennent meilleurs lorsque le
printemps arrive lorsque les conditions
climatiques sont plus favorables
manifestement c'était le cas en france
c'est le cas dans toute l'europe
je vais réussir kull - le printemps
arrive bientôt est ce qu'il sera chaud
tout de suite c'est ce qu'il faudra
attendre un peu plus quand une fois ce
sont des paramètres qui ne sont pas
contrôlables humainement
toujours est il que nous espérons
véritablement qu'avec ces mesures de
freinage nous puissions passer le cap
nous puissions passer cette vague et de
l'autre côté de cette vague retrouver à
la fois le printemps mais par rapport à
l'année dernière quelque chose de
fondamentalement nouveau la protection
de la population par la vaccination est
donc ce sont ces deux facteurs conjugués
qui devrait nous permettre de donner des
perspectives aux français et donc
lorsque la pression sanitaires se fera
plus basse parce que nous serons sortis
de cette dynamique épidémique et qu'en
parallèle nous avons pu protéger avec
davantage de france est fragile et que
nous verrons les formes graves futé vous
savez nous les voyons chuté chez les
personnes âgées aujourd'hui
l'incidence chez les personnes âgées
elle est en baisse
les décès dans les ehpad sont en chute
libre les cas graves chez les personnes
très âgées celles qui
en réanimation et qui décède le plus
souvent ces cas graves sont en réduction
conséquente ça c'est l'effet de la
vaccination c'est visible et ça va se
renforcer et se prolonger donc si les
mesures sont nécessaires aujourd'hui
hélas et pour quelques semaines
nous espérons vraiment et nous en avons
la conviction que ce n'est que pour
quelques pour quelques semaines
et gageons que ce sera pour la dernière
fois je voudrais si vous permettez
d'abord donné une pression extrême
importante pour nos concitoyens
concernant le couvre-feu à 19h pour
l'ensemble du territoire national il
entre en vigueur comme toutes les
mesures que j'ai annoncée dès le présent
week-end dès le présent week-end et je
voudrais dire avec mes mots si vous le
permettez là la réponse aux aveux
d'échec
1 c'est incontestablement toujours
extrêmement difficile d'annoncer à nos
concitoyens
des mesures qui sont qui représente pour
eux dans leur vie quotidienne
d'autant que ça dure depuis un an des
restrictions
soyons très clairs alors nous y sommes
contraints mais pour moi le présente à
un public pour l'ensemble du
gouvernement
la question est de savoir si nous nous
sommes donné tous les moyens pour le
retarder jusqu'à la dernière extrémité
tous les moyens et je pense que de ce
point de vue là toujours chaque jour
gagné par rapport à l'adoption de telles
mesures alors que par ailleurs nous
avons la course contre la montre vers la
vaccination sans doute vers le printemps
toujours est un jour gagner encore une
fois des pays voisins ont confiné bien
avant nous et bien la période où c'est
tout se retrousser les manches a été une
période je crois extrêmement utile nous
constatons ce soir que
la pandémie le variant progresse très
fortement que la pression hospitalière
est trop forte
il était donc indispensable évidemment
nous accompagnerons tous les secteurs
professionnels comme nous l'avons
toujours fait mais il était
indispensable de prendre des mesures
fortes qui vous l'avez constaté vont
au-delà du week-end comme nous l'avions
décidé jusqu'à présent
bonsoir monsieur près ministres
concernés ce ministre est pas brillant
pour l'agencé france presse afp
mais ce communiste vous avez indiqué que
certains l'accent ne trouvait pas
preneur à en faire un rendez-vous notre
pas preneur d'une part et puis d'autre
part on a appris cette semaine selon un
sondage que à peine 20% des français
avait confiance dans le vaccin
astrazeneca alors des gares serait-il
important de revoir les critères
d'éligibilité pour se faire vacciner
certains disent pourquoi pas finalement
ouvrir dès maintenant au prix jeunes
ceux notamment qui sont susceptibles
d'avoir et animations la vaccination
deuxième question vous avez indiqué vous
faire vacciner demain une quarantaine de
députés de la majorité se sont portés
volontaires et aussi pour se faire
vacciner alors qu'ils ne sont pas dans
les critères d'éligibilité
est ce que vous vous estimez que c'est
une bonne idée merci alors peut-être
d'avoir aligné sur les indications
ce vaccin est affecté un jeu juste je
vous confirme
pardon je vous confirme à toutes et à
tous effectivement que avec ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine
l'attractivité du vaccin astrazeneca ne
va pas rien a diminué qu'effectivement
on a vu des les rendez vous se libérer
ou ne pas être n'aurais je vous le
confirme dans un certain nombre de
centres de vaccination pour cette raison
et je vais m'en je le répète parce que
j'en ai la conviction aussi parce que je
suis responsable à tous les sens du
terme de l'autorisation et de la
diffusion de ce vaccin donc j'agis en
responsabilité je surveille de façon
extrêmement attentive toutes les données
dites de pharmacovigilance
bon nous l'avons suspendu vous
connaissez toutes et tous les motifs
justement pour restaurer la confiance
l' agence européenne s'est prononcée
nous allons avoir la réponse à notre
question sur les indications précises
par la has
mais il faut à tout prix non seulement
reprendre la vaccination mais aussi que
nos concitoyens aient confiance dans ce
vaccin et dans tous les vaccins dont je
permets de vous rappeler toutes et à
tous faisant petit effort de retour en
arrière les premiers vaccins qui sont
apparus étaient des vaccins arn messager
c'est à dire des techniques tout à fait
nouvelles files heures et moderne tout à
fait vous avez rendu compte
toutes et tous ici des fortes réticences
que chez nos concitoyens suscitait ces
vaccins à tort mais des fortes
réticences bon on a vacciné et
maintenant ces vaccins ont un grand
succès de steam vous verrez qu'il en ira
de même d'astrazeneca et des vaccins et
qui vont arriver à partir du mois
prochain monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
parmi les personnes prioritaires
on compte 15 millions de français
tout le monde ne voudra pas se faire
vacciner ou ne pourra pas être vaccinés
parfois pour des contre indications
ça fait quand même du monde à vacciner
aujourd'hui nous sommes bientôt à ces
millions de français qui auront reçu une
première injection
donc il ça ça laisse encore de la marge
pour vacciner toutes les personnes les
plus prioritaires pourquoi est-ce qu'on
priorise vraiment ces gens là parce que
c'est ce qu'ils font les formes graves
c'est ce qui va dans les hôpitaux c'est
ceux qui ont le risque de mourir c'est
la priorité des priorités c'est celle
que nous nous sommes fixés depuis le
premier jour c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons démarré un peu plus
lentement que nos voisins mais c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
affichons 90% de vaccination dans les
ehpad et un taux de couverture vaccinale
chez les personnes les plus âgées donc
les plus fragiles de notre pays qui n'a
rien à envier à nos à nos voisins
bientôt nous aurons pu vacciner
massivement ce public prioritaire est
alors ouvrir à d'autres publics
mais il reste encore un petit peu de
temps sachez néanmoins que les arrivées
livraisons de vaccins notamment le
vaccin pfizer
augmenté de façon très conséquente dans
les prochaines semaines à partir d'avril
c'est près de 2 millions de doses par
semaine par semaine 8 millions de doses
dans le mois donc ça va nous permettre
vraiment d'amplifier le mois d'avril est
un mois de transition dans
l'accélération qui va permettre vraiment
d'amplifier la vaccination la protection
et moi tant qu'il y aura un français ou
une française âgée de 85 ans qui me dira
et j'en vois quand je me déplace je n'ai
pas encore réussi à avoir de rendez-vous
dans un centre de vaccination
tant que j'aurai des médecins des
infirmiers libéraux qui me diront qu'il
y à des français qu'ils sont parfois en
précarité dans les quartiers populaires
donc il ya des personnes âgées qui sont
isolées qui n'ont pas encore pu
bénéficier d'une vaccination à domicile
je me battrai pour eux et je ferai tout
pour que ces personnes puissent être
vaccinés dans les meilleurs délais et en
priorité
ensuite nous pourrons discuter de la
vaccination tout à fait légitime et très
attendu je le sais parler français des
autres catégories de population qui sont
moins à risque
voilà nos priorités ajoute si le
ministre ne permet que si la confiance
un astre à zenica je suis persuadé
qu'elle va revenir mais qu'elle tardait
un peu c'est clair toutes les doses qui
ne serait pas utilisée à ce moment là je
crois que c'est un peu le sens de votre
question telle que je n'ai compris
doivent être réalloués d'accord doivent
être alloués pas question de perdre des
doses sa première chose et la deuxième
chose que je n'ai pas dit mais dans la
montée en charge des arrivées de doses
qui est programmée évidemment il est de
notre devoir de faire un effort
spécifique pour les territoires on l'a
déjà fait qu'ils sont dans la situation
de risque épidémique plus fort que nous
avons déjà encore une fois nous avons
augmentés des livraisons de doses dans
les semaines passées
jean rémi baudot pour europe 1 monsieur
le premier ministre début janvier depuis
janvier on a compris que la stratégie
était de repousser un éventuel
reconfirme ans diriez vous que ce soir
face à un certain principe de réalité
bien ce pari n'a pas été gagnée et puis
monsieur ministre on s'éclairait à sont
aujourd'hui quasi saturé mais le 27 août
dernier vous avez dit si la situation
nécessite 12 mille lits de réanimation
pourront être disponibles
alors on a compris que ce n'était pas
simple de forme et que ça prend du temps
de recruter ça peut prendre évidemment
des années mais pourquoi avoir fait
cette promesse fin août si on n'était
pas en capacité de la tenir merci
messieurs jeu comme à l'x paris ii n'a
pas été gagnée c'est comme l'aveu
d'échec de tout à l'heure je ne partage
pas cette analyse je l'ait déjà indiqué
dans mon intervention tout le monde
effectivement disait dès le 29 janvier
vous devriez re confiné vous souvenez de
cela je pense nous ne l'avons pas fait
nous n'avons pas fait et je pense que
nous avons bien fait parce que hein
les risques les conséquences d'un
confinement sont quand même lourde pour
nos concitoyens et que faire le choix de
se donner les moyens d'en reculer
l'échéance est un choix judicieux
non nous sommes des gens très
pragmatique vous m'entendez vous êtes
fidèle à ses conférences de presse
je vous ai je crois que vous pouvez m'en
donner acte toujours dit toujours dit
nous faisons tout pour l'éviter nous
devons tenir ensemble
mais si l'épidémie flambent
alors nous prendrons des mesures pense
que personne
tout est public et transparent ne peut
contester que j'ai tenus de manière
constante de ce discours je constate
avec vous je constate avec vous et il
serait tout à fait irresponsable de ma
part d'agir autrement qu'aujourd'hui en
tout cas dans un certain nombre de
territoires
la situation est devenue suffisamment
préoccupante pour que nous prenions les
mesures adaptées et proportionnées au
moment où on doit les prendre
parce qu'elle s'impose
ce ministre vous m'avez interrogé sur
les lits de réanimation
d'abord sachez que l'année dernière pour
la première vague
nous sommes montés à plus de dix mille
lits de réanimation qui accueillait des
malades du cobp ide et des malades orco
vide ce que j'ai essayé d'expliquer tout
à l'heure c'est que nous montons en
charge et nous déployons les lits de
réanimation au fur et à mesure des
besoins
ces besoins ils vont vite chaque jour
dans les hôpitaux parisiens et entre 20
et 50 malades de plus en réa que la
veille donc ça nécessite de dilater sadc
site transformé des unités de soins hier
où nous étions il avait déjà augmenté de
14 à 18 lits et ils peuvent encore
augmenté à 22 lits et ils pourront si
besoin augmenté à 25 lits mais comment
est ce qu'ils feront ils arrêteront
toutes les chirurgies
ils appelleront les malades qui doit qui
doivent être opérés en leur disant on ne
peut plus vous opérez ils transformeront
les blocs opératoires en chambre de
réanimation
ils demanderont aux anesthésistes aux
infirmières de bloc opératoire de venir
en réanimation soigner les malades en
réanimation il des doubleront les
chambres pour m deux lits là où ils
peuvent mettre dolly à la place dani
nous avons les respirateurs nous avons
les moniteurs cardiaques
nous avons les traitements nous avons
les matériels de protection et nous
avons l'engagement de nos soignants
comprenez que plus vous montez le nombre
de lits plus cela se fait au détriment
des soins programmés pour des malades
qui n'ont pas le coc vide et qui
aspirent légitimement aussi à être
soigné quand vous transformer comme
c'était le cas hier à l'hôpital de
poissy
une unité de soins intensifs de
neurologie vasculaire qui prend en
charge des patients qui font des
accidents vasculaires cérébraux avec des
handicaps
si vous devez transformer une partie de
cette unité en lits de réanimation
qu'ovide vous pouvez le faire mais cela
se fait au détriment d'autres soins donc
nous le faisons au fur et à mesure des
besoins exprimés
ça ne servirait strictement à rien
d'avoir aujourd'hui douze mille lits de
réanimation prêt à attendre des malades
alors que nous avons plus de quatre
mille malades du co lead et trois mâles
à trois milles plus de 3000 malades
orco vide c'est à dire à peu près 7000
7500 malades au total en réanimation
donc nous suivons la capacité d'accueil
des malades suis l'afflux des malades
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que c'est la
logique est donc nous sommes encore
capables de monter en déployant des
moyens considérables
je le dise
avec la fatigue des soignants mais ne
souhaitons pas y arriver puisque cela
impliquerait d'avoir des conséquences
pour les autres français et cela
impliquerait de restructurer totalement
le fonctionnement des soins dans nos
pays nous l'avons fait nous sommes en
mesure de le faire mais nous ne voulons
pas en arriver là ajoute une quand bien
même nous aurions cent mille lits de
réanimation
nous devrions prendre des mesures de la
nature de celles que nous prenons notre
objectif c'est quand même d'éviter que
les gens se contaminer soit malade
la finalité tout ça c'est pas que les
gens finissent dans des lits de
réanimation et donc c'est bien par des
mesures par la vaccination je le répète
par des mesures de freinage par
évidemment le respect de tous les gestes
barrières que nous luttons contre cette
épidémie
donc la question n'est pas de dire on
laisse tout le monde se contaminer tout
le monde va en réanimation et on
augmente les capacités de réalisation
c'est pas comme ça qu'on lutte contre
une épidémie il faut je le veux je le
dis bien rappeler cet élément essentiel
qui est d'ailleurs à la source même des
décisions que nous avons annoncé ce soir
merci beaucoup non